you know it put another thought in me
um I've been going back to church right
every week every weekend now every
Sunday from the I mean you because you
know my story yeah but um I think going
back to my home church and um
you know because I I was hurt so bad by
it right but then there's just like it's
just people you know and it's their
families and it's their community and
it's it made me realize oh this is what
I'm missing out on because I left here
in five four three oh God damn it one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast we
are back in the studio we have Ed Park
VP here once again what's up
um yes we haven't shot one since before
New Year's yeah it was like November or
something and you were in uh Seattle I
did oh that's cold ass Seattle holy [__]
I flew in like during the ice storm so
we were like the last flight to come in
but getting there was a [__] [__]
too by the way because
um that week before Christmas there was
a snowstorm first and so we couldn't get
on a flight on Tuesday so we had to go
out on like a Thursday morning but then
all the flights from Burbank LAX
um and Ontario I guess downtown yeah is
all booked and they told us the only
flights that were in [__] where the hell
is uh Coachella at again Palm Spring
Palm Springs Jesus we [__] drove
three and a half hours to Palm Springs
to catch a flight back to Seattle we're
being we're going home for the holidays
God damn it that's crazy dude we did it
and the flight was also delayed three
hours
is that is that that's the same time
around the whole Southwest debacle right
yes dude that [__] was nuts so for for
me I drove back for Christmas instead
because my mom wanted to give me a bunch
of panchan yeah so panchan is yeah
yeah I'll get flags over there
smells like a bomb
a bomb of flavor
freaking um
if you want to give me a bunch of
content so it was me my brother Muriel
we decided to drive down and then a
bunch of my friends were like oh yeah
like I'm just gonna fly this way faster
yeah they got stuck in Sacramento to
like the 31st of December oh my God yeah
because there was all their Southwest
flights were canceled yeah and uh they
got the refund but then they didn't want
to spend money on another ticket so they
just stayed back further for us we just
had like an hour delay on traffic
um because I decided to take the 99
instead of the five uh people who took
the five so if you guys are not from
California uh if you go from like Los
Angeles to to the Bay Area you could
either take the Pacific coast for the
scenic route the scenic right will she
adds like three or four hours it's
[__] dumb and then you could take the
five which is like a straight shot for
like 300 miles and then you switch over
to the 99 for us
we decided to take the 99 instead
because I had a feeling the five was
going to be super busy and then every
all my friends went on the five they got
home like three or four hours later good
God yeah because that that road trip
alone sucks but if you're on a road trip
and stuck in traffic I can't [__]
stand it and there's no exit yeah the
closest exit on the five is like 10
miles away from each other every time so
it's it's literally the worst but that
Southwest flight [__] everybody over
and they said it was a huge debacle we
took Alaska and it was yeah like I said
the last one to get into Seattle before
they closed all the runways because
there was an ice storm came after so
when we landed that was the roughest
Landing of my life I literally I
realized I was grabbing the armrest
super tight because it was snowing so
much right yeah and the tarmac had
frozen over oh [__] that yeah but the
thing is we land right we land at
midnight
because of the ice and all the other
planes couldn't leave the their [__]
terminals we were stuck on the tarmac
for another two and a half hours get the
[__] out of [__] suck and they turned
off all the air yeah and I'm just we're
just sitting there and you know I think
I just fell asleep but I woke up
sweating yeah it sucked ass that that I
don't understand why they can't turn on
the [__] air conditioner on the
tarmac yet so so we we land at 2 30 in
the morning right the rental cars
[__] close at 1am oh my God so Dan
and I are just [__] sitting at the
rental car stations just nobody's there
and nothing so we call the holiday
Christmas movie dude we're gonna get
home I swear we we had a call um an Uber
to take us to a Motel 6 so we could just
spend the night there oh my God it must
smell like [__] semen and [__]
shame it was pretty crusty yeah but you
know and the next morning we leave holy
[__] everything is covered in like an
inch of ice everything and then all the
videos went viral of people slipping and
sliding and seeing Seattle and that's
literally what it was like it was just
I've never seen it like that before
that's so interesting because I didn't
realize how everybody else got [__]
too what was the reason for this crazy
weather because if you're in Los Angeles
um I know everybody makes this joke oh
they finally get [__] rain and they
freak out no this was a [__] unreal it
was a [__] ton of rain it's not even
it's not El Nino season either right
yeah so for people out there who get
like consistent rain like if you're in
Houston you're like oh whatever Los
Angeles wasn't built for this type of
rain so the infrastructure here just
just gets [__] like the freeway was
flooded yeah so it was it was pretty
[__] terrible it rained for like
three four weeks straight and it was how
long it was a I think it was like two
weeks straight and it was like a
torrential downpour yeah and for a city
that's not built like that people get
[__] over do you know how much it
[__] sucks to come back from Seattle
where it's raining and cold and snowy to
come to L.A and it was wrecking rain
here like cold like God damn it like
that [__] sucks but it's part of the
I guess there was a huge Arctic chill
coming from Alaska that has to do with
the cycle of the currents on the Pacific
Ocean so that's why the Northwest is so
green all that Arctic you know whatever
the air atmosphere comes down to Seattle
and just becomes rain
and then it just dries up when it gets
down to California but then that [__] I
don't know what the [__] the explanation
is but it went all the way down to
Mexico that's [__] yeah that's why
everyone on the west coast was getting
this rain but then it didn't go past the
Rockies because that's just how yeah all
the time
what did you do during Christmas dude so
I went to church right it's the first
time I went back to my home Church in
like eight years which which is was the
the big Mega big it's not a mega church
but it's a big Korean church right so
the the Army Sanctuary is like a dome
kind of I guess [__] it's big if it's
like a thousand plus people oh that's a
big Korean Church yeah so it's the first
Korean Church in Washington state and
this last year was their 50th
Anniversary so that's pretty old for
Korean American Church yeah and I get
there like 10-15 minutes late and so
there's no seats in the back obviously
right and I'm like [__] I'm just going
to chill out in the lobby and the
Usher's like Oh Come here I'll catch you
sick and announcing all right I'll
follow him but little I know it was at
the way [__] front I hate that [__]
all the way in the front and then it's
just I haven't been to this church in a
long time I just forgot how big it was
you know how lonely that walk is when
you're walking along the shame the Walk
of Christian shame oh my gosh so yeah
that was weird but you know it put
another thought in me
um I've been going back to church right
every week every weekend no every Sunday
I mean you because you know my story
yeah but um I think going back to my
home church and um you know because I I
was hurt so bad by it right but then
there's just like it's just people you
know and there's their families and this
is their community
and it's it made me realize oh this is
what I'm missing out on because I left
here and it put something in me like hey
let me just try to find this again in LA
you know and uh I went to Citizens it
used to be called Sovereign Grace oh
that's right that's right yeah yeah yeah
yeah I used to call it sobering Grace
actually because everyone everybody was
[__] dogs on Saturday yeah sobering
Grace you know what's so funny about
Korean churches in LA and this is the
one thing that I found out because okay
yeah so I went to uh you know a bunch of
Korean churches in Sacramento right but
when you're in a small town like your
church just has also a small town Vibes
too yeah and typically what I found from
a lot of small town Vibe churches they
don't deal with as much [__] as like
Mega City churches right because I don't
know what it is but the faith seems to
be stronger in smaller churches than it
is in some of these Biggers so when I
when I first came to La I went to come
downstairs I went to a full a couple of
Korean churches and everybody was
blasted the next day because they would
go out in K-Town yeah get [__] drunk
smoke do whatever the [__] they want but
on Sunday they would come through and
they're all hung over yeah I'm like yo
what the [__] is going on here I've
never experienced that until I came to
the churches in La which is a very very
interesting experience because like you
would see people just trying to
[__] I know you ain't praying
you are so [__] hungover like I'm
like looking at these guys like damn
their faith is really strong
like you've been praying it was super
hard for 15 minutes wow this is crazy
and I just see them just go oh my God
you guys are drunk yeah dude I mean like
and that's one of those things that I'm
coming through with like why I'm doing
this it's part of my deconstruction
process I really think it's part of my
therapy too to redefine what church
means to me because of that idea of a
community right that it's enough for
drunk hungover people to want to be a
part of this even though they're not so
holy you know that there is something
special about it now I know where I
stand in my beliefs you know and it's
not like you know I'm turning my life
back to Jesus yeah and we're committing
my life David will you baptize me oh
this podcast he goes so I'm going back
to Iraq no no you're not you're not
going back to Iraq I'm going to go to
Ukraine yeah no that's the thing if I
was still in that mindset I would for
sure get on a flight to Ukraine I know
you would not
allow it I'm not there there which makes
me think of all my friends back in that
day like yo why didn't you guys stop me
yeah no clap for you no honestly it was
like nobody because of my mindset at the
time was like nobody was going to stop
me from doing that but yeah I'm I'm
looking at it at a light like look at
the Italians and the Irish a huge part
of their culture is the Catholic Church
yeah right it's tied to who they are and
despite all the the reputation that they
have right like we said too like we
could show up hungover like they show up
to mass still right and you kind of
Wonder like what is it about this
ancient way of thinking that you still
want to be a part of
and I'm trying to reconnect with that
too like and it's the idea of a
community but that
um it's also a part of my identity like
I can't deny that you can call it my
moral compass
um it's still based from a Christian
perspective right yeah yeah yeah so I I
see that the Italian Americans the Irish
Americans and I'm like okay I'm a
korean-american presbyterian Protestant
and I'll just do it like that I'll go to
church you know this is a part of who I
am this is how I grew up this is the
things we did and I'll stay here and
I'll participate with that you know I
don't take communion you know
um I don't you know I'm not a heavily
involved in Bible study obviously like
but I'm showing up because this is a
part of who I am I feel like that's how
I uh it's interesting because when I
went back to Sacramento that you bring
this up because I talked to a few people
who uh like Korean people that went to
church and then some people who went
church with me they no longer go to
church and they all went through this
whole identity crisis right which is the
idea of do I just did I just go to
church because my parents forced me to
or do I actually believe in this stuff
right and
the hardest part of I think about like
having faith in anything is just
you're gonna have to battle honestly
it's like logic
you know and it's a tough conversation
to have with people because that that
Community part is one of the biggest
reasons why I think any type of religion
becomes very successful yeah it is that
human interaction the the feeling of
belonging yeah the feeling of like being
heard which most religions that I
believe anyways were for a lot of people
who converted to Christianity that I met
converted because of something that
happened in their life that was terrible
right so whether it was a certain type
of trauma whether they
um I don't know went through a divorce
and they lost everything and then during
this time God came to them and saved
them yeah right
um but there's people like us who just
grew up in it yeah right where it was it
was ritualistic every Sunday we would
get dressed up and we would go to church
we would see our friends whether we did
bad things or not but this was a part of
our everyday yeah right and I think the
hard part for me was
because I I haven't gone to church since
pandemic yeah um just because I don't
want to catch Kobe again I mean it's now
to a point where covet is pretty it's
really really manageable yeah minus the
people who are like immunocompromised I
mean but that's with any type of virus
or a disease but um I just don't want to
catch it again but now I think okay I'm
just gonna I think I should be fine now
I've caught this [__] twice like I'm
pretty boosted if I catch it again I'll
probably get sick but I'm not gonna die
yeah so um I'm probably gonna go back
but the the weird thing is like every
time I go back to church like I always
dread it and I think it's because when I
was a kid I was forced to wake up and go
yeah right you have to go when it starts
to become a choice is when it starts to
feel a little different because now you
can make the conscious decision to
be a part of this yeah I think when I
started going back to church it just not
only did it feel like familiar it felt
really good and that's like a weird
feeling right because I wasn't forced to
go I woke up I did my hair I did
everything you know what I mean and I
went there and I sat down and I listened
to this sermon and it made me feel
better so I was like okay whether it's
something that I truly believe or not
something about this thing that I've had
since I was a kid makes me feel good so
I'm I think I'm gonna stick with this
yeah right for for new people who come
to the religion I don't know what that
feels like because it was a part of my
everyday like it's a part of my
Nostalgia as a kid it's a part of my
relationship with my parents if I give
up this religion I give up more than
just a religion I give up a huge part of
my not just my identity but of my
comfort yeah right
um and how I participate I'm not doing
small small group I'm not doing any of
that stuff I'm going there for the
sermon the good word and it makes me
feel good and then I walk out yeah you
know you know yeah but the way we grew
up remember how how they used to judge
people who do that oh yeah for sure oh
you lukewarm
so much my whole life
it's like oh you either you're either
hot for God or you're cold you can't be
lukewarm you know yeah dude I forgot
about that oh God but but I guess
because we're older now and we realize
not everything is so black and white
that I can be okay and ride in that gray
area that I want to find peace there in
the grave I found that me being so
binary in my beliefs like this is it
this is Christianity this is what you're
supposed to do is what ended up with me
going to Iraq right yeah but then I do
need to find look there's a piece in the
area right here where you know you are
not in control where you are giving it
up you know to Jesus or God or whatever
or literally for me it's accepting the
positive parts of church because you
know me for the last you know so many
years
um it's confession time
I was [__] on Christians so hard
like fake ass Christians yeah because I
was angry and
um I did it a lot like if I saw someone
being a [__] hypocrite oh I'd called
him out on it and I look back on it like
I was I was a massive [__] dick as I
did it do I apologize for doing it not I
I apologize for the the tone in in the
way I did it yeah but I do believe that
fake ass Christians should be called out
for the hypocrisy
but I am now coming out of that to
really be like okay
um
where do I like fit in and what can I
contribute in a positive manner instead
of trying to destroy Christian's face
yes that was my that was my thing
because like the most dangerous thing
about someone who really knows a Bible
in theology right is going to a
Christian and deconstructing their faith
and literally telling them I do this
like you're not actually a Christian bro
if I'm going to hell I'll see you there
with me yeah like I'd say that yeah yeah
you know and so now I am like look if I
know and I have this knowledge like
there's still a positive way in bringing
this out to make help people be better
people instead of just saying you're a
piece of [__] yeah you know because even
still like that's not the gospel either
right it's fulfilling the Redemption of
your faith yeah I think the hard part
about the hypocrisy thing is you know
because yeah I definitely call people
out on that stuff not because I was this
ideal version of what a Christian is
supposed to be or somebody who believes
in the faith it was just I would always
chew out people that would be it was a
person who would condemn others when
they're like they're the piece of [__]
talk
going to hell bro like you're going out
of your way to make other people feel
like [__] because of their lukewarm
Faith yeah but at the same time it's
like
brought do you deal drugs
[__] are you talking about man and you
know I don't know whether it's like a
coping mechanism for them to make them
feel better about them understanding
they're doing something that's not
christ-like so they have to put it on
church to get the brownie points so
hopefully in this dangerous lifestyle
they live in they'll make it to Heaven
yeah yeah yeah I mean that's the
gangster Faith yeah exactly like one of
the weirdest things too I got this
message from this guy uh
and I don't know if it's necessarily I
think it was just because of the
the it's not the Christian faith part
but he did go to my church right and
this was a guy that um
he grew up in a nicer area right and
there was these dudes that were like
fake contests like you know fake
gangsters right yeah I grew up in a not
so nice area I was never a gangster I've
said this multiple times on the podcast
and most of the stories that I tell is
like people that I grew up around that
were older right because I wasn't really
involved in that stuff I was just in the
periphery right this podcast is brought
to you by secret society if you guys
don't know this is a premium fashion
Basics line that I started with a few
friends of mine five years ago and we're
going strong so if you guys don't know
about secret society let me fill you in
now in a world where everybody and their
mom is selling clothes
um we are not the same so when you guys
buy clothes you guys know that typically
you'll have two options fast fashion is
cheap looks cheap feels cheap same cut
same crap stitching and you know it's
going to fall apart after a few washes I
hate it or you can go to high-end
fashion you pay an arm and a leg up to
200 to 300 for a piece but you buy it
for the namesake and on top of that
there's a lot of those high-end brands
that just use blanks with their logo
slapped on it and you don't know but you
still pay 300 for it we are not fast
fashion and we are not these other
high-end Brands a lot of pieces if not
of majority yards are cut and so garment
dyed and hand selected fabrics and every
piece from old new uh from previous
lines goes with everything else that we
have so premium fashion bases are not
easy to make but we fill in that gap
between the two options that clothing
offers the new element collection has
been restocked so check it out at
secretsociety.com that's
www.s c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y.com
and so
being in the periphery of people who
like literally have like killed and
murdered people it's you kind of absorb
some of that stuff right to a certain
extent yeah and so there are these dudes
at church who I know what area they grew
up in very nice right and they had their
version of what what it was to be tough
right and then there was my shitty
[__] area where these guys would eat
these [__] alive posers exactly
[__] posers posers and so this guy I
remember
uh one time at church like I'm you know
my dad's like a a leader in the church
and you know he took it upon himself to
always Punk the younger Korean kids
which it was a rite of passage for a lot
but this guy was really excessive with
it right to the point where it was like
a power thing yeah and I just remember
one time
um uh because I was bigger I was the
size when I was 14. and so he was trying
to punk me and I was just kind of
playing nice and then you know church
and then I just remember I walked up to
him and I shoved them against like these
like curtains that separate the
sanctuary also if you ever [__] touch
my [__] murder you dude yeah I'm like
this is church and my dad's like a
leader in here but I swear to God if I
meet you I'll [__] murder you and so
I remember this guy would always try to
bully me and I just got sick of it
because he also knows like he and I had
to grow up very differently yeah and I
think he enjoyed being able to do that
to me at church because nothing was
going to happen to him but I was like
dude when church ends I'll [__] kill
you like I'll literally find like some
of my older like homies and they'll
[__] murder you yeah don't touch me
and it got to that point but lo and
behold years ago I'm on YouTube and he
messages me out of nowhere he goes yo
man I just wanna let you know super
proud of you blah blah blah I just want
to like reach out to you and say hey can
you do like videos like on the subject
of like bullying people I'm like
bro
I'm not even [__] making this about I
gotta find this on face I don't use
Facebook anymore but he DM me that [__]
on Facebook yeah that triggered me super
[__] hard yeah and I just wrote back
to him and was like hey you [__]
hypocrite I was like if it's if it's
something that you're so passionate
about because you feel guilty for the
way you treated people at church then
you do your own [__] video don't put
that [__] on me and also we're not
friends so don't [__] hit me up
asking me about this [__] without number
one you should probably apologize to me
yeah right because I was like you
remember when I had to check you [__]
hard as a 14 year old and you're like
this 18 year old kid right like this
little kid [__] punked you so it's
like if you wanted to do that you should
do it yourself and I was at that type of
hypocrisy I hated it's like do you think
that all the [__] that you did just
erases yeah like it doesn't it doesn't
just disappear you know so that was the
type of Christian that I hated a lot
it's just they I don't know what it is
maybe it's like them trying to like
Gaslight you and say oh I never did that
yeah you know I was like no I
specifically remember you did but I I
that's the part of the faith I think a
lot of people hate right yeah and I
think those people are the ones that do
the most damage like you could
participate in this faith and try to
better yourself every day but when you
start feeling like you're in a position
to lecture other people about like
morality and piousness when you're not
even at that position yeah it's the part
that [__] kills me like it just
because it makes me want to just I'll
[__] go I'll see you there yeah no
for sure like that's the [__] that
triggers me too and it brings up the
anger like I had a lot of thought about
I'm going to say not thoughts as much as
it's ruminations about my past and how
to rectify the hurt and the pain but
like massively massively it was about
hypocrisy and I was always fighting it
with my words oh my God so when the
George Floyd stuff and the BLM stuff was
going down in 2020 like everyone's
talking about it on social media
this one girl she's Korean man she wrote
all these things about how she's a
minority so she knows but the Bible's
appointed Trump to be our president and
we should trust him and that white
people aren't racist cops aren't racist
all these things that people didn't need
to hear
yeah what's what's going on with her
right and so she was talking about even
like affirmative action [__] too where
it was like
um she was dating a wide receiver of the
Seattle Seahawks at the time but he's on
the practice squad okay and she's saying
he can't make the team and play on
Sundays because they put black people
above white people
is like [__] legit at the time like
okay what are you [__] talking about
do you think a multi-billion dollar
company gives a [__] about your race
yeah they give a [__] if you could
perform yeah and they give a [__] if you
could bring in dollars your boyfriend
sucks
all right that's what it means that's
what it [__] that's why he's there it's
not because of Reverse Racism like she's
claiming if there was any anybody that
could say they don't see colors of
sports team
they're just like does he catch yeah is
he fast how long can I keep let me just
put it in perspective for people when
you're in and I I know this only because
I know people on the sport
when you are acquired from like let's
say a bass I only know this from
basketball like from a basketball team
they assess you from head to toe and
they have people appointed to you to
assess how what your longevity is yeah
they could based on like your tendon
strength like everything it's kind of
weird how scientific it is and they go
before they even pick up a player they
go oh he's talented down he's [__]
dope and you might see some players how
come they didn't pick him up they got
assessed they go um from what we've seen
from him most likely he'll probably be
able to play
maybe five years strong so this is what
we should ask what they were saying
about Andrew Bynum and like the Lakers
drafting him was a huge like plunder
because they knew those things before
they drafted exactly so it's pretty I I
wouldn't say there's no politics that's
involved in it because once again I'm
not an athlete I don't know and there's
politics in everything yeah but [__]
shut up like shut up yeah so it's like
long story short it was just me going
off on her I literally said you're not a
[__] Christian yeah you don't know
Jesus and you're a racist and by the way
racism is a sin you know you don't
[__] know yeah you know like and I
was just saying like it's the same thing
if I go to hell I'll see you there yeah
you know and then
do I look back and cringe at what I said
honestly no am I apologetic to no she
said some heinous [__] yeah you know and
like when people write those type of
things right it's like objectively
speaking what is your end goal what is
your mission here right it's like oh my
mission is the truth is it is it are you
trying to project that you think you
know what you're talking about when you
don't have a goddamn clue yeah you know
well you know the whole weird thing
about you know during that time of like
BLM and you know there there have been a
lot of stuff you know obviously you know
like shady under dealings all this other
stuff but we'll we'll address that as
the organization as the organization
right uh the weird thing is like
the people who had the most opinions
about whether it's like Asian or like
let's say black people and during BLM
was the people who have no black friends
oh blackout that was the weirdest thing
it's like so on social media yeah so you
you never had a conversation really with
like another person like who who is a
black American yeah never hung out with
them and yeah if I look at your school
yearbook there was nobody there so yeah
I I had a conversation with the girl
um
it was a friend of a friend who I don't
I don't really know that well but they
they're pretty Pleasant right they're
just a little [__] crazy and kooky
well they have very harsh stances on a
lot of things a lot of things for them
are black and white right yeah
um I had a two hour conversation with
this girl based on her opinions of like
just black Americans right and what's
going on and I literally asked her this
one question and you know she was really
receptive to this right and I was like
if I looked in your yearbook right and I
opened up this yearbook of yours
how many black people are in there right
and she goes well I didn't have a lot of
black people I was like cool have you
attended do you even have black friends
because yeah I have one and then
describes like okay first of all you're
Korean and that black person is a
koreaboo like they they idolize black
like Korean culture yeah and so their
perception already I was like does that
also let me ask you this where did you
meet that black friend right they're
like oh they go to my church I was like
who are their friends they're all Korean
and I'm like okay yeah so they might not
be it doesn't take away from them being
a black American themselves but their
perspective is cute because they want
you to like them right now if I took you
to my area right and I kicked and you
kicked it with my friends right
how uncomfortable would that make you
feel I was like let me just put it like
this if somebody didn't go out because
she grew up in Korea if somebody didn't
grow up in Korea right and they told you
this is how Korean people are they never
had a Korean fan never shared a Korean
meal never nothing else wouldn't that
bother you right and I was like how is
it that you're doing the same thing
right and she goes okay I cannot I can
understand that right and I think that's
where a lot of people come from right
where they don't have a perspective So
and I've and I've said this a lot too
where my perspective based on a lot of
people is from my personal interactions
with them right
so like any culture too there's always
going to be an outlier or there's going
to be a certain amount of people that
are going to [__] up your perception of
who they are because a lot of my friends
who are Asian right that I don't kick it
with were also gang members yeah so is
my perception of Asian culture based on
these people yeah like all Asians are
gangsters exactly
yeah that was a weird conversation to
have you know with them I mean that
attitude is
um
well that jumping the gun attitude yeah
to speak before you really know let's
say
um we saw it happen this past week
um there was tragedy
um you know speaking on we we had our
new years and then we there's Lunar New
Years yeah
um and if you haven't heard the news
there was a shooting
um and then after that there was another
shooting in San Mateo both yeah Asian
Asians aren't even shooting each other
or shooting them yeah mass shootings in
San Mateo is another it was an Asian man
like older man who shot up a mushroom
farm you know what the [__] yeah no more
enoki mushrooms and they [__] just
went off like what the [__] what is that
about there's no clue but the the thing
that like took over Twitter for a while
was all the
bone-headed Asian Americans speaking out
when they heard the news of the shooting
blaming white supremacy
they jumped the gun and blend blame
white supremacy and we we talked about
this to that vicarious PTSD yeah that
you like because of you know perhaps
Atlanta or the past few years of you
know the Asian hate crimes and such you
you couldn't sit and wait and maybe
thoughts and prayers for a sec you know
yeah yeah yeah just that you know before
the news came out and everyone's just
started blaming white supremacy and
that's [__] embarrassing for all of
us yeah yeah you know and so like the
the attitude of us doing that I
what do I attribute that to narcissism I
don't know is this idea to have to
project something and say it out loud
before you even know anything about it
yeah no simulu but yeah
it's a thing it's a it's a Twitter
culture yeah
um but yeah the the shootings like um I
don't know if you want to expand more on
that yeah I mean that was such a weird
I think that was the most like
disappointing thing right because when
this happened and I'm being 100 honest I
wasn't thinking about the ethnicity of
the shooter right I was like what the
[__] happened and this is so sad yeah
but when you when you do go on Twitter
once again Twitter it's a you shouldn't
get your news there yeah any type of
like social media app where you where
people can talk freely without any type
of consequence whatsoever then you're
gonna hear some heinous [__] right and a
lot of people too they're going to
project their own issues and Trauma out
right but the you know there was like
stop Asian hate who the [__] was it was
a white people was it black people and
you found out it was like a 72 year old
Asian man yeah everybody went dead
silent but you didn't even care to see
how the victims were what what the what
the outcome was like it was immediate
outrage and trying to find somebody to
pin this on right yeah that didn't look
like you yeah right
um but that's like the poison of what
social media does right it it whether
you think that you're so much above it
or not if you are on a social media app
24 [__] seven it molds your mind yeah
those those opinions that you read even
you could only ignore it for a certain
extent right and that happens to me a
lot too or I have to step back and be
like okay I think I'm getting kind of
caught up in this [__] because I've
been seeing a lot of stuff
and you know so but basically what
happened was uh Lunar New Year so if you
guys go to like Alhambra Monterey Park
the sgv set San Gabriel Valley it's a
heavily heavily populated Asian area
specifically with uh Chinese immigrants
Taiwanese immigrants so Lunar New Year
there is a big [__] deal yeah
um when this happened I think everybody
assumed that it was a shooting that
happened at the new Lunar New Year
festival and that people Asian people
were targeted because they were
celebrating right and that was the
immediate jump yeah right which I'll be
honest I thought that too
um but did you think it was white
supremacy no did you think our lives are
in the hands of white supremacy no but
that's like the hot ticket thing right
it's just white supremacy white
supremacy and you know people get caught
up with these hot ticket words and they
like to use it because they want the
thumbs up and the little Twitter likes
right right so that's that's what
they're gonna do it for everybody is
motivated by this type of [__] there
were content creators too like I think
this is the weird thing like that should
happen right and then people sent me
tick tocks where people are like this is
what happened in Monterey Park I'm like
listen to you heartless heartless little
[__] like the first thing that you
think about is dude this is gonna be hot
content
and breaking news exactly and there's
just people on their stupid little
[__] iPhone mics you know hey guys
Monterey Park is a is a heavily heavily
popular heavily populated Asian area and
uh what we're gonna do here this it's
like dog it happened like [__] 20
minutes ago yeah like how the [__] are
you already doing a tick tock on this
get a [__] journalism degree
[__] exactly and so but now it's
not about whether the information is
right is who can say it first and it's
these kids who are just you are becoming
[__] heartless human beings out in
Indiana
it's just a weird thing to see right and
so this gunman came through
um if you all don't know old Asian
people for some reason love ballroom
dancing salsa and ballroom dancing is
their [__] yeah like I've Muriel's on uh
also does like salsa or like Zumba or
Ballroom yeah and it's her [__] Joy I
don't know what it is that once they get
the Pama going you know they get a
little older and they're like ballroom
dancing it is yeah
um
uh this older Asian man who apparently
went to this Ballroom right he was a
former dancer there he was a former
dancer there so he goes there and he
lights up this place 10 people uh 10
people injured 10 people murdered half
women Half Men semi-automatic weapon yes
with an extended clip both illegal in
California who knows I think it had a
silencer on it because the barrel looked
[__] huge canister was it a tech
night or a Uzi I don't remember but it
was all illegal it was all illegal [__]
but it was like painted like white and
like camel colors it was like I mean
like what the who did you steal your
incel grandson's gun like what the f
where the [__] did you get this [__] I
will say this too and I know this is a
very serious subject but shout outs to
Asian people aging really well because
they said it was a 50 year old man
they're like it was a 50 or 40 year old
man and they're like no 72. we age
really [__] well dude
um despite being a [__] murderer I'm
glad you're dead but I'm glad you have a
really good skincare regimen yeah and so
this guy [__] lights this place up
tries to go to another Ballroom area and
tries yeah so there was a guy
Brandon say Brandon said I believe Robin
can you double check that the the guy
who stopped the gunman the hero the hero
yeah I'll look up his name yes please
um there was a young man who by the way
I would have never expected him to step
in and save damn save the day right
because he looks like a very quiet
normal looking Asian dude and not to say
that all Asian dudes are quiet but he
looks like the type that you know
honestly is just a really sweet guy yeah
you know I would expect some some I
don't know some birdly loudmouth Asian
dude because I was hearing his interview
and he was super calm and maybe that's
why he was able to stop him because he
can assess situations really well
because for sure if I saw I think my um
confirmation bias or um would have just
kicked in and if I saw an Asian guy with
a gun I would just been like good
morning and I would have walked down
like I wouldn't have been able to
process it right because who expects a
70 year old 72 year old Asian guy to
walk in with a semi-automatic weapon
yeah and you're thinking oh that's real
yeah now that you say that way like I
would be like huh that's an odd sight
but then my mind would probably be to
mind my business but damn this guy was
on his toes he wrestled the gun out of
his hand and that's how we saw what kind
of gun he was using yeah what was his
name
I'm gonna butcher the last name but it
was Brandon and the last name was
spelled t-s-a-y
and then I looked up the type of gun and
it was a semi-automatic pistol with an
extended large capacity magazine illegal
illegal yeah yeah
damn so yeah I mean uh I mean the the
I I mean because he's a hero like I
don't want to take anything away from
him but then um
he just like smashed the gun and like
was like get out of here get out of here
yeah go away
I mean like yeah why did apprehend him I
don't I don't know maybe because he sees
like an old Asian man he's just like oh
that could you know the shock the shock
or something because I
76 times that's when we will call you
that's when we call you right this guy
has a [__] gun yeah and he's out to
murder people but um like the weirdest
thing like I don't know and you know
I want people to understand this too
when we talk about these situations or
when anybody talks about this right
everybody likes to speak with a certain
amount of bravado they go in this
situation this is what I would have done
I can only say that in certain things
where I've been in that situation so
when we talked about that that kid out
in Vegas because I've been in those
situations I had a pretty clear idea of
what I would have done because I have
done it yeah right multiple times so
in this situation I always say this and
it's a really smart thing to hear I
heard it from somebody else where they
say the the oddest thing about this is
like people with the most limited amount
of experience
always says that says that they're in a
situation with the best version of
themselves like this is what I would
have done yeah in your superhero mind
yeah I've talked about me having a gun
pulled on me and in my mind I [__]
somersaulted out the way I got my gut
and I went pew pew pew pew I froze I
just went oh oh yeah like you don't know
you don't know like we're always the
best version of ourselves yeah all the
time in that situation I'm pretty sure
that I probably would have got killed
because I would never in my mind picture
a 72 year old Asian man with an illegal
automatic pistol with an extended clip
coming in I would have just looked at it
and been like oh here's a toy yeah have
a good day and I would have walked out
yeah like uh maybe he's buying it for
his grandkid or something like the thing
he got away from
I guess wherever he was and he there was
a man search for this guy right and then
they ended up finding his body in an old
folks home right where he lived I guess
in his car he shot himself in the head
like a white in a white van or something
yeah right um I guess the car had more
weapons and stuff or something but this
the shitty thing is it's like
it sucks that he gets to take his life
because he doesn't get to pay for what
he's done right and he got to go out his
own way he got to do his own thing leave
it leave this earth the way that he
wanted to which is [__] unfair yeah
when I look at that situation
and on top of that we don't even get to
know his motive we don't get to know why
there's no
the uncertainty is what people feel
really uncomfortable with right I would
say it's the Injustice yeah because now
there will be no justice because he is a
[__] coward yeah
like I was reading um a bunch of people
who were victims and there was like this
old lady who you know has been dancing
there for years and then she lost her
life like this this is like this is so
sad and now now we have that topic of
gun control coming back up again and I
don't know what the solution is right
yeah and it's so hard to say for
somebody like me who number one I don't
like guns yeah right but I also had to
think about things in a realistic
standpoint of you will never ever take
the guns from American hands you can't
like you you absolutely cannot no matter
how much we want it it's just there like
once again the gun that he killed these
people with was illegal yeah it wasn't
through legal means so the idea that he
was able to get this modified weapon or
if he modified it himself it was all
through illegal means which is going to
happen either way right and I think
that's like a reality that a lot of
people have a hard time grasping right
yeah especially for a lot of people who
don't know guns who aren't around guns
who haven't been around people with guns
growing up you think every single one of
my friends who what a gun well they're
not really friends but the people that I
grew up around had guns do you think
they were grabbed their legal means they
were all [__] illegal and they had
crazy [__] on them so I don't know what
the general solution are we just [__]
yeah I mean like uh we were having
dinner that night it happened
um Mario's friends came from Korea right
[Music]
um and then during dinner we we were
talking about the shooting and then
that's all I was curious about their
position because like they're visiting
America right like I was like is this
this is probably like your first time
like experiencing this like being within
a vicinity like 10 15 miles from it you
know and I think she was saying like how
her her friends were texting her like
are you okay yeah yeah yeah like that
and it's like it was interesting to see
the perspective of someone from another
country to be like to see us
I don't know if we're apathetic but
we're just like damn okay another one
yeah again we um so I was having so I
shot a JK news and then we went to go
eat at a Sichuan spot and that shooting
happened I think like a couple blocks
when we were eating and we were outside
uh talking outside when it happened oh
my God but you know we we didn't hear
anything and then when I got home Joe
texted me saying dude this happened like
a couple blocks from what we were
standing outside so like we could have
died yeah and we don't know these things
and then you know my mom calls me too
and then she's like super [__]
worried she goes are you okay what
happened and you know I [__] around
and I was like I died you know she hates
it when I joke like that and I was like
I basically told her I was like
I'm not gonna die I'll never die you
know which you're joking around makes
her feel better but that's a concern my
mom had where she's just like oh [__]
like I know that he goes out in that
area a lot and I actually was literally
there yeah and you know we
that's a very scary and sobering feeling
where every time I've heard of a
massacre it was never this close it was
somewhere else it was in Vegas it was I
don't know [__] Virginia but
um I've heard from a cop uh cop buddies
who told me that um there are so many
shootings that happen like you just are
fortunate you only get to hear the few
that are on the next news yeah it's it's
that prevalent where people are getting
shot and killed every day there was a
time where I was shooting a this content
with this group of people and it wasn't
a building off on Sunset and in front of
me there was a Carl's Jr where there was
cops all around well there was a guy on
like a dude on a bike that was stabbing
people and then he went into the Carl's
Jr to stab people up and then he came
out and then he got shot yeah that
didn't make the news holy [__] I was
right there it didn't make the [__]
news and that was like one of like a
million like a hundred things that
happened that day so something bigger
probably happened so it wasn't covered
yeah which is kind of nuts or maybe
somebody wrote a small article about it
but to me I'm thinking yo this is going
to be huge on the news
didn't hear a [__] nobody heard about
it yeah I mean like I was in when I was
in Iraq um I made friends with a
translator with the Marines
and um he was in the thick of it in
mosul you know and when he would he was
our guide all around our bill and
he was a guy whose sister died in a car
bomb and then a week later his fiancee
was killed on Car Bomb you know so he
hates terrorists and then um
you know we had a really great
relationship for a couple months and
then he had to go out on this mission to
mosul
and we were sitting around the living
room and the home we're staying at and
then it's BBC News and it's like boom
breaking news
um an IED A Car Bomb like something just
has exploded and has killed five
American soldiers right and on PBC News
um and we're just getting reports and
we're like holy [__] so we we try to
call our friend he's not picking up and
then like 15 minutes later he calls us
and and then he's like it's so crazy
you're calling me right now and he's
like we know we saw it on the news he's
like yes a bomb just blew up and then I
said yeah we heard five American
soldiers die and he's like what what the
[__] what are you talking about he's
like that's what the news says the news
just say five American soldiers died and
he said there's 200 dead people
men women and children and the News want
to say five American soldiers died oh
wow and he was [__] pissed yeah and
and so I I get that the idea of this
Injustice that's happening like this is
what's happening to our people and you
guys
Don't Care About Us you care about you
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know and in the
same manner like perhaps that's what's
happening when we are reacting that way
and we jump do we care about what
happened to the victims and the families
do we care about us so we blame white
supremacy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
saying it's such a terrible conversation
to have like
I don't know like I
I think it hit home for a lot of like
our friends who kind of grew up in this
area you know who grew up in like the
sgv yeah like the way they were affected
by it was way different from me it's
home right it's home this is home like
yeah they've seen this Lunar New Year
Festival happen every year growing up
for them right their friends their
families everybody celebrates it here so
for me like it you know hit me like any
other tragedy but when I was reading
like the
the post that other people were writing
I'm like oh [__] like this hits them
really close to home yeah because it
could have been any of their parents it
could have been their friends and family
it makes them hug hug their you know
loved ones a little tighter that day but
man dude like I've
it was weird I'm not gonna lie it was
weird seeing that person being Asian
yeah that's weird right it was kind of
like the [__] like I mean when's the
when's the last one Virginia Tech
Virginia Virginia Tech yeah and that was
a shock too like oh [__] but we knew his
motivation and reasons and I think not
things that that's super comforting but
it is comforting more comforting knowing
the person's motive to understand to
kind of like help us understand our
feelings because we're like why why why
would such a thing happen you know I
mean and when
this guy [__] shoots himself and
there's nothing it's just we live in
this trauma and tragedy yeah and now
it's going to take a long time for a lot
of people to recover from things like
this because that Virginia Tech kid he
was he was a victim of bullying right
yeah all sorts of yeah like mental
issues and stuff too yeah but um like
hearing that I remember there was an
onslaught of like we need to stop
bullying people because it's causing
them to you know do crazy [__] like
they're they're gaining a lot of trauma
yeah and that was a positive movement
that happened from that because there
was I mean listen like I remember when
that video came out everybody was
looking at me but like are you a
Virginia Tech it sucked to be Korean
I'll tell you that yeah you know and
then he took these [__] weird ass
little photos with a hammer like this
yeah because he was the old boy because
that's the movie poster and he's like
yeah oh you in so weirdo [__] weird
you're not supposed to like that guy
exactly you're supposed to hate yeah it
was yeah man like um I think this is
like a really they're actually giving I
forgot who was doing this but I saw
closed captioning not available
[Music]
like your your brain could just make
that money and go go to the Festival
your dick said let's go to his birthday
let's go to this birthday party right
but
um it was yeah that was that was a
sobering I mean fact too so the news was
governor Gavin Newsom uh Sacramento is a
capital correct yeah that's where he's
at he flew down to uh La came to sgv or
Monterey Park to speak to the people in
the community and as he was speaking
another shooting happened up north
that's crazy and it was another old
Asian American I want to say Asian
American I don't know his status but
just an older Asian man who shot other
Asian Farm Workers out of mushroom and
nobody knows why
just apparently I think apparently yeah
I think he was killed I have no idea
like what the motives are but then
I think it's just the the tragedy on top
of the other tragedy it's like who
I don't know like this man up north it
seems like
it's not because oh he heard a shooting
now I'm gonna do my thing I felt like
once it came out another Asian man did
it he was like you know my [__] I'm
gonna do it that's the feeling I get you
know people were talking about this too
where you know the news has a certain
amount of responsibility for
highlighting these things because
they're saying that it's it could be a
possible incentive or trigger something
to somebody else to react away because
there's people who just want notoriety
yeah they they want to be Infamous so
they'll see that and they go oh well now
it's my turn they'll write their
Manifesto and
um
there's a big conversation with that
with the Netflix documentaries
glorifying serial killers where people
are having issues with it and
specifically with the Jeffrey Dahmer one
that came out I could have watched the
Jeffrey Dahmer thing because I read too
much about it it's like I already read
his Wikipedia one day when I was bored
it's like I don't think I want to watch
that happen that's what happened to me
so I read up about a pretty
like pretty extensively yeah and then
when I was like cool I'm gonna watch
this I watched it and that made me sick
yeah it's very hard to make me sick
watching something but only because the
stuff that I watch is fictitious this is
real real it happened it was a such an
odd thing to see and especially because
like
I think like the the part that kind of
was very unsettling and I know this
happened in the past but just hearing
about it upset me was when that young
kid
um it was the Cambodian campaign this
guy got a [__] lobotomized his butt
naked screaming and then the cops come
in and they tell the lady who's like
screaming at him like look I wear shit's
going on across the street tells her to
shut the [__] up stop causing trouble
yeah takes that kid and sends him right
back you know and it was you know this
is the type where you could say there
was a lot of racial Injustice yeah you
know and that was like one of the
biggest things that happened like in the
news it's like the reason why these
people died is because the cops failed
to do their job because they looked at
the black community like they didn't
care about them dark-skinned people they
didn't give a [__] about him and that's
the part that [__] me up really hard
and um that first scene too of him just
trying to like sexually assault and rape
that young black man it was so visceral
and real and it was worse than what I
pictured in my head yeah yeah and I
think that's after the first episode was
like I can't watch this now this is too
real if this was a fictitious story I'd
be able to stomach it and be like okay
this this director and write really got
into the head of the psychopath but
knowing that that was a real person yeah
I'm like ugh I can't do this like that's
the thing about I don't know if you want
to call it trauma porn but perhaps it is
oh for sure it draws people to want to
watch that because I mean people as of
late have become obsessed with True
Crime right and I think that might be
the attachment to it but it is I feel
like degenerating us
I think that kind of [__] isn't good for
us like he was almost out of American
Consciousness yeah and probably that I
felt like maybe that was like them
thinking that's a good time to bring
this [__] up you know because it was
it's been 50 years well look at the um
the creator of Black Mirror he hasn't
done a new season because I think he put
out a statement saying that it was he or
she I can't remember but saying that
this is so real to what's happening
right now and
the world has so much like trauma and
like Darkness yeah I don't think we need
this yeah and so that's when they're
like okay time for this Jeffrey Dahmer
one yeah so it filled that whole people
like that too and people talk about how
um you will definitely Bond over
negative and traumatic Expressions
rather than happiness yeah people almost
prefer it right that's what you see on
online talking [__] is way better than
spreading like positivity of Love yeah
right people bond with that stuff and
it's it's a pretty empty Bond you know
I think um for us I guess as a society
or whatever like there has to be some
kind of Reckoning
with like like that's the thing we do
need a Black Mirror phone quote and
perhaps like uh that that's what those
shows like black mirror and like the
Twilight Zone and the outer limits those
shows were to show us hypotheticals
about us as human beings in the
situations we're in that's why like I
feel like those shows would be important
today but then um but in a sense like
one TV show can't do this do that for us
for like how many Americans are there
now 350 million yeah right like to
change an entire culture or anything
like that especially because you can't
make any laws like uh to prevent such
things or to force people to do anything
at all
um as far as your own personal thought
goes
but then for for us we do have to look
at ourselves to be like why we enjoy
certain things and why we are
entertained you know and also uh where
we stand like when people get hurt
you know and where where our empathy
goes if I could interject as a fan of
True Crime but I also recognize the
problem with the entertainment aspect of
it today there's a side of it as a woman
where it's taught me a lot of tips and
tricks on how to be aware of my
surroundings and stay safe and what to
do in instances like that
but with the whole um the murder of the
four students in Idaho and everything
that was going on with that a lot of
people online were like deciding that
the roommates that survived were should
be suspects and like torturing these
poor survivors and now a lot of those
internet people who are talking about
that are actually being sued now that a
suspect is in custody and things are
kind of calming down and it's just such
an interesting thought to think that
like there's a weird I don't know like
people
think they have a right to comment on
those things when it's just like you can
just be a silent Observer and respectful
of family it's like a weird blurry area
but yeah it's
content creation Now right so people are
almost waiting for some [__] to happen
so they have content to talk about right
it's an expression of their Obsession
yeah yeah yeah and like I mean I if they
wanted to do another Black Mirror season
they could make that happen pretty easy
over just the [__] that's happening
right now yeah and like the stuff that
they kind of relatively predicted with
like for example the uh there was the
episode of Black Mirror where they had
the rating system
right and it happened in China
dude have you seen the rules like
there's a poster of like what earns you
social points and what like loses social
points it's so fascinating we will bring
that up another time okay for sure
um well guys that actually wraps this
episode of The Genius brain podcast
um if you guys uh want us to talk about
some other specific stuff just write in
the comments below you can follow Ed at
edparkvp uh on Instagram uh are you
doing your podcast again yes I this
Sunday I'm gonna put up a Toy Story 4 uh
breakdown there we go so you can check
out uh Ed's podcast
um a Bible study at Momo Bible study at
Momo uh GJ spring every Sundays at 12
p.m we'll see you all next time all
right peace